huge developments in the growing hunter
biden scandal and his father
has some major explaining to do the
president-elect's son
under federal investigation and it
involves a lot more than just his
tax affairs like hunter claimed
yesterday
sources telling fox news the probe
started in 2018
and investigators are looking into
suspicious money from
foreign countries including china
pressure now building on joe biden to
speak out publicly
after repeatedly claiming that he and
his son hunter
did nothing wrong no one
has indicated of any consequence that
anything was done
wrong or illegally by me or by
my son my son has not made money
in terms of this thing about uh what are
you talking about
china is a bunch of garbage nobody
believes that there's absolutely
zero basis to the accusation
that i enacted anyway inappropriately or
that my son did
you know there's not one single bit of
evidence
not one little tiny bit to just anything
done was wrong
dana i have a feeling we might be
playing some of those soundbites for
a long period of time going forward so
let me just set this up for you here if
they're investigating hunter biden's
business deals with china
and tony babilinski says joe was in on
those business deals with china
might joe be a little worried about
where this investigation could be going
not from their public comments but i can
i can't imagine
that internally on the campaign that
they are
at the transition that they're thinking
that this is great news for setting up a
new government
um one of the people for the cabinet
that has not been named yet jesse
um is the attorney general and one of
the things joe biden promised over and
over again in the campaign
is that the justice department would be
under his administration
completely independent okay so
we have talked before about how eric
holder considered
his position um to be one of to protect
uh president obama people have said that
attorney general bill barr
has gone over and beyond to protect
donald trump so
what kind of independence might this new
cabinet member have because
this is not an investigation that's
going to end on january 19th
as andy mccarthy was explaining today it
was
covert for a long time because that's
where you're trying to interview
witnesses but there comes a point
when you have to go public with it so
now we know that all of these things
that we were talking about in october
that we were told
was russian russian disinformation and
we were scolded
for talking about such russian
disinformation
now we have a situation where you can
look back at all of that and you could
play clips all day long
but going forward one of the things i'm
really paying attention to is who does
he choose
as that attorney general as this is
going to be under that federal
investigation arm
that's an excellent point and you know
we were told that
president trump was not allowed to
interfere in the justice department at
all and if there is any hint of joe
biden using his attorney general to shut
anything down well
then that is wrong got felt isn't it
that is just
wrong it is an outrage jesse
i can barely contain myself you know
who's overjoyed right now
right now kamala harris is on here on
the harry and david website
picking out the perfect gift basket for
tony babalinsky
and maybe i don't know a crack pipe for
hunter but every time i look at hunter
i'm thinking the only thing laundered
about him
is his cash he is a walking hamper of
disaster
and i i realized that the secret to
maintaining like a self-destructive
lifestyle without consequence
is going to law school first because
when you think about all the rascals
the avenatti's the bill clintons the
michael cohens the alley mcbeals
they all like they all know how to live
their lives on the edge
without getting arrested but only last
for so long
but now i want to get serious the worst
part about this whole scandal
is the uh the 50s the 50
senior intel officer signed letter do
you remember that
when the former senior intelligence
officer signed a letter
pre-election uh claiming that this story
on hunter biden
quote had all the classic earmarks as as
dana said of a russian information
operation
so i think the real question is who got
them to create that document
who got those 50 people together and
then got them linked up with the media
and why was it done at this specific
moment obviously to affect an election
so this is a really huge story you're
talking
basically influencing election you had
50
senior intel officers all this effort to
help him out
clearly he was orchestrated and i think
that this is something that
you know if this had happened on the
other side oh my god
you'd have like woodward and bernstein
running down the
you know pennsylvania avenue in their
underwear screaming worse than watergate
no greg i can't get that out of my head
now that's not what i was thinking about
very sexy geraldo i want to go to you on
the diamond situation you brought this
up yesterday you have experience in
giving people diamonds
when you give someone a dime you do like
considerable usually
usually that's kind of a romantic
gesture
um but you have a chinese communist guy
giving hunter biden another guy
a three carat diamond try
explain that to me it's a great way
to give value to give you know
essentially
cash without giving the dirty money so
you give them a rock that's worth a
bunch of money
you put the rock in your pocket no one
says anything about it so you've just
received a gigantic
income without having to declare it and
i think that those are the kinds of
things that are at the heart
of his tax evasion uh probe
but as is apparent this is much bigger
than just
hunters taxes this is the the
implication here
with this grand jury since 2018 is that
here in the words of the senate
there exists a vast whale transactions
between
and among the biden family and chinese
nationals
this is a huge story and let me say also
as the father of five
if i were to fly if i had a plane i was
gonna fly to my with my kid
to china and i'm the vice president of
the united states and my kid is with me
what's my adult kid doing there i mean
obviously he's not gonna just tag along
with my official functions
wouldn't the dad say to the son hey son
how's that business going or hey son
what are you going to do when i'm at the
great wall or when i'm
in the uh in the uh the hidden palace
you know of course when biden says i
never ever
spoke about my son's business dealings
in ukraine or china
you know as much as he seems such a
decent fellow
it's it kind of does not jive with our
our normal experiences jesse
yeah and um just common sense emily
geraldo just brought this up the
millions and millions in transactions
between the chinese
and the extended biden family this was
not a political prosecution
this originally was flagged by hunter's
banks
they noticed suspicious activity from
all these international wires
and they were the ones that raised the
red flags not any politician
not any senator it was a bank
that's exactly right and not only for
the amount of those transactions
as in the uh like the quantity of them
but also the quantity of the money
and the timing which was so fascinating
the same day he opens a line of credit
he charges a hundred grand
i do have to say that just overall that
the breadth
of these multiple investigations that
span states
and jurisdictions and issues and family
members
it cannot be overstated nor obviously
can it be reduced to quote tax affairs
and we know that the bidens have this
history of oversimplifying
whenever their behavior or their conduct
is questioned
and this is no exception now i think
also it's important to point out
my second point was dana's which is that
it's crucial for optics and otherwise
who biden selects as his attorney
general and last quick point
that the media loves a democrat we know
this but they love a scandal too
and as it is revealed more the findings
the subpoenas and everything in between
about this
and we learn what joe biden's knowledge
really was this could be a really
effective spear for the gop
in the midterms in 2022.
all right when going forward i want all
of my earnings to be paid in diamonds
that seems delicious